oggi voglio parlare di cultura e nello
specifico di sesso
un po' strano effettivamente il sesso
non è la prima cosa che viene in mente
quando si nomina la cultura Anzi
associare questi due termini in effetti
fa un po' impressione fa un po' senso
come immaginare Corrado Augias che fa un
esattamente così
pure la sessualità negli esseri umani e
solo in parte determinata dalla biologia
mentre è in larga parte determinata
dalla cultura Siamo esseri culturali
Creiamo un sistema di valori condivisi
Ed in base a questi agiamo i nostri
comportamenti anche comportamenti
sessuali Inoltre la salute sessuale è
stata dichiarata dalle Nazioni Unite uno
dei diritti fondamentali per il
benessere psicofisico della persona in
accordo con l'organizzazione Mondiale
della sanità Ma perché voglio parlare di
sesso Perché voglio farmi regalare un
vibratore da un'azienda di sex toys
anche
ma non solo partiamo dal principio Io
sono un'attrice nel 2015 ho inventato un
personaggio Martina dell'ombra un
personaggio di satira che però è stato
preso per vero ma nella realtà un
personaggio che non esiste un
personaggio di finzione come Paperino
Babbo Natale Di Maio
da quando faccio questo lavoro
e sono sul web ricevo ogni giorno
centinaia di commenti quasi tutti a
sfondo sessuale e detengono incredibile
record il record di pompinara sul web
siamo io Laura Boldrini e Selvaggia
Lucarelli che ogni anno ci contendiamo a
fare l'argento il bronzo del titolo di
questo insulto che poi pompinara non è
un insulto è una qualifica
come dire scalpellatore
e poi pompini li fanno tutti
li fanno le donne li fanno gli uomini
anzi sembra che gli uomini li facciano
meglio delle donne Il signore in seconda
fila Mi conferma
Sì grazie
Però visto che è così perché ad un uomo
non viene detto pompinaro
perché quello che noi pensiamo sul sesso
deriva dalla nostra cultura e
storicamente per le donne tutte quelle
attività che avessero a che fare con il
pene ma non con la riproduzione erano
considerate delle serie ce lo dimostrano
i classici della letteratura del teatro
nel mondo classico La donna ha due
versioni prima di conoscere il pene
quindi vergine dolce romantica ma
rincoglionita
e dopo aver conosciuto il pene quindi
non più vergine e intelligente Smart
furba Ma stronza il pene nel mondo
classico funziona un po' come la laurea
ti dà più Skills Ma ti lascia anche
attività con il mondo
Dopo anni
di insulti a sfondo sessuale
ho pensato Sì forse hanno ragione forse
il sesso e il mio destino ma non nel
senso che devo aprire un canale only
fans Ma nel senso che forse Devo
approfondire la storia del sesso devo
diventare una studiosa devo diventare La
Barbera del pompino
perché la storia ci insegna sempre
qualcosa su di noi anche la storia del
sesso ad esempio la fellatio compare in
due eventi storici particolarmente
rilevanti il primo siamo nel 1899 in
Francia a Parigi e nel palazzo
presidenziale lo stimato presidente
Felix Floor si sta preparando per andare
a casa Come di consueto visto che sono
le 7 di sera o almeno così sembra
all'improvviso il capo gabinetto sento
un urlo provenire dallo studiolo Azzurro
del presidente corre apre la porta e si
ritrova davanti questa scena il
presidente per terra nudo probabilmente
morto e davanti a lui
per terra inginocchiata c'è Madame Stan
High sua storica amante con le ciocche
di capelli incastrate tra le dita rigide
del presidente morente
Sì è esattamente come sembra
Il presidente è morto di colpo mentre la
sua amante le stava Praticando una
vigorosa fellatio nello studio
presidenziale
la notizia fa il giro del mondo diventa
uno scandalo e lo scrittore George
clement'sò in merito al presidente dirà
I love you vivere Cesar e le mosse
ha voluto vivere come Cesare è morto
come Pompeo
come è venuto se ne è andato
lasciando comunque intendere
stai lasciando intendere che non fosse
comunque un brutto modo di morire mentre
per quanto riguarda l'avvenente Madame
steinhael Le fu costretta a lasciare
Parigi visto ancora a lungo ma dovette
portare con sé per sempre Il nomignolo
di pompa funebre
e queste storie
andiamo avanti di 100 anni siamo nel
1998 in America una mattina di gennaio i
principali tabloid americani escono con
una notizia incredibile
l'allora presidente degli Stati Uniti
Bill Clinton intrattiene una relazione
extra coniugale con la stagista Monica
Lewinsky il presidente si affretta a
negare tutto e nega anche sotto
giuramento Peccato che poco dopo
usciranno effettivamente le
intercettazioni che dimostrano che la
signorina levischi praticasse del sesso
orale al presidente negli studi
presidenziali
gli uomini di tutto il mondo
insorgono a difesa del presidente al
grido di un pompino non è tradimento
ma nonostante questo il presidente
finisce sotto in pitchment ed è
costretto a dimettersi che cosa ci
dimostrano queste due storie
innanzitutto che la fellatio è una
pratica molto amata dai presidenti
ma anche che è un ottimo strumento
politico per far crollare governi
che cosa sappiamo invece del
corrispettivo del sesso orale femminile
ne sappiamo in realtà pochissimo per
vari motivi Innanzitutto perché il
piacere è femminile nella storia è
sempre stato poco considerato quasi per
niente E poi perché la storia è stata in
gran parte raccontata dagli uomini
Quindi non sappiamo come davvero le
donne di un tempo vivessero la propria
intimità di sicuro sappiamo che
praticare il sesso orale a qualcuno Era
considerato un po un gesto di
sottomissione quindi in una visione del
maschio virile veniva considerata
umiliante solo le donne di grande potere
potevano aspirare a pretendere del sesso
orale infatti È nota la leggenda della
imperatrice cinese hutsetiang la quale
pretendeva che l'emissari di missionari
esteri che andavano a trovarla le
praticassero
un cunnilingus
mica scema
meglio di una scatola di cioccolatini
il piacere femminile è stato in effetti
talmente poco considerato nella storia
che nel 1913 lo scienziato evelock Ellis
teorizza e inventa il massaggio pelvico
Ovvero la stimolazione manuale del
clitoride come cura contro l'isteria
isteria malattia tipicamente femminile
alla quale venivano imputati qualunque
tipo di sintomi praticamente qualunque
cosa avesse una donna veniva ricondotta
all'isteria mal di testa capogiri
svenimenti anche l'epilessia
E appunto un gruppo di medici teorizza
il fatto che attraverso il massaggio
pelvico si potesse raggiungere sempre
con Maggiore intensità il culmine
raggiungendo lo stato del parossismo e
sferico praticamente l'orgasmo
e che questo curasse i sintomi
dell'isteria pensate a queste poveracce
che dovevano fingersi isteriche per
godere
è proprio per evitare che i medici
dovessero sforzarsi nel praticare
manualmente questo massaggio pelvico che
era abbastanza impegnativo che venne
inventato qualche anno dopo il primo
vibratore elettrico per scopi medici e
diventerà in pochissimo tempo uno degli
elettrodomestici più venduti al mondo
in realtà il piacere è sempre stato
molto ostacolato dalla politica dalla
religione ma anche dalla stessa scienza
infatti andiamo a vedere che cosa dice
un manuale
scientifico del 1700 In merito ad una
determinata pratica che si pensava
causasse questi sintomi
disturbi dello stomaco e della
digestione perdita di appetito fame
vorace vomito nausea indebolimento degli
organi della respirazione tosse
raucedine paralisi indebolimento
dell'organo della generazione mancanza
di libido mal di schiena disturbi
dell'occhio dell'orecchio diminuzione
totale dei poteri del corpo pallone
magrezza brufoli sul viso declino dei
poteri intellettuali perdita di memoria
attacchi di rabbia follia idiozia
epilessia febbre e infine suicidio
stiamo parlando della masturbazione
se fosse vero saremmo tutti morti
e questo è Samuel
del 1712
ovviamente erano tutte falsità
e oggi i tempi sono molto Cambiati
Possiamo tranquillamente guardare
YouPorn senza la paura di morire Tra
l'altro ci sofferenze
però nonostante questo nonostante la
rivoluzione sessuale nonostante le lotte
per i diritti civili nonostante la
nostra sessualità se si è effettivamente
evoluta con l'evoluzione della nostra
società tutt'oggi il sesso e l'eros
rimane un argomento tabù rimane un
argomento di cui è difficile parlare che
viene giudicato inappropriato che viene
giudicato volgare parlare di sesso viene
limitato ad ambiti medici accademici o
al massimo divulgativi oppure in ambiti
prettamente goliardici E tutt'oggi manca
un serio programma di educazione
sessuale nelle scuole Anzi questa viene
fortemente ostacolata da molte parti
politiche nonostante come abbiamo detto
la salute sessuale sia uno dei diritti
fondamentali per il benessere
psicofisico della persona
Ma perché
il potere ha sempre cercato di reprimere
controllare e a volte sopprimere la
sessualità degli individui
Perché il sesso porta con sé il concetto
di piacere e desiderio
è un essere umano che conosce il proprio
desiderio ed esplora il proprio piacere
è un essere umano che si conosce che sa
chi è che si autodetermina In definitiva
è un essere umano libero e il potere
teme da sempre la libertà delle persone
ed è proprio per questo che dobbiamo
parlare liberamente di sesso continuare
a praticarlo continuare ad esplorare e a
nutrire il nostro desiderio e il nostro
piacere perché nutrendo questi noi
nutriamo ogni giorno la nostra profonda
libertà
[Applauso]